chiffres à on a bravé bien des tempêtes
pour pouvoir venir chercher ses enfants
dans cette école de côte-des-neiges une
école toute simple pourtant aussi
enfants apprennent les mathématiques
l'histoire la géographie comme tous les
autres enfants du québec
moi je suis
ceux vivant
yoann est très en colère contre notre
gouvernement bien qu'il ait grandi au
québec lui n'a jamais eu cours de
mathématiques de français ou d'anglais
seulement une éducation religieuse ce
qui est contraire à la loi sur
l'instruction publique
d'après notre l'été raconter les
politiciens du québec sont coupables de
mon ignorance et je leur en veux d'itélé
il y a quatre ans chiffre à yoann ont
fui la communauté tosh de boisbriand
justement pour que leurs enfants ne
soient pas ignorants